[Music]
hello everyone
so in the last part of the lecture we
had
started discussing the concept of
traction
and uh next what we are going to discuss
is
how this concept of traction uh leads to
the
concept of stress now or rather
more specifically the state of stress at
a point
now the moment i say this phrase
state of stress at a point i believe
many of you
will start remembering what you start
studied
in your first year mechanics as well as
in your fluid mechanics course
and certainly thermoplate signs for the
manufacturing guys
and that is fine now the unfortunate
thing is in many of the textbooks for
mechanics of solids
uh this sort of similarity between fluid
mechanics
and mechanics of solids is not at all
highlighted
now this is something which i wish to
remedy uh
in our course here so we you will see
that there is a lot of lot of similarity
at least in the initial parts
um of how we discuss uh or how we
develop the concept of stress starting
from
fraction in fact the derivation
that leads to the connection between
fraction
the mathematical connection between the
traction
and stress you will see it it is
exactly the same that you have studied
in fluid mechanics i believe that part
was already covered
nevertheless i still wish to highlight
it here in mechanics of solids
uh not just as a way of recap but to
highlight one very important thing which
you may not have realized
while studying fluid mechanics and that
is
uh you see
this relation between traction and
stress
it is mentioned in many of the textbooks
okay in many of the textbooks of certain
fluid mechanics
and many of the textbooks of mechanics
of solids or solid mechanics
mechanics of materials uh however
especially when coming from the
background of mechanics of solids
or mechanics of materials what is
sometimes
missed by those authors is
is that they forget to mention or
somehow they do not highlight it
that this connection between traction
and stress
holds true even if the body is not
in static equilibrium i repeat this
connection that will
that we will develop we will discuss it
very well uh
between traction and stress it is valid
whether or not the body is in static
equilibrium
even if the body is in motion no problem
that
relation will hold true so this is the
this is the thing which you may not have
realized while studying field mechanics
because there this thing the the
feed particles were not in static
equilibrium because
because even though statics was covered
perhaps in the first
in the initial chapter of field
mechanics of your field mechanics course
or thermofit science
but later on you certainly studied fluid
dynamics
okay the fluid was in motion and even
then
the uh the famous navier-stokes equation
for newtonian fluids
that held true and in the derivation of
the navier-stokes equation you still had
that connection between
the traction and the stresses embedded
so this
connection is very true even if the
thing is not in planting equilibrium
and the same concept holds true for
solid mechanics also
now uh i think the reason that
most authors of these textbooks they do
not
or they forget to mention it is because
most of the problems that we study
within the scope of our syllabus
and certainly that will be again the
case for our
third year uh course of mechanics of
solid state which you are studying
is that almost all the problems will be
uh will be in static equilibrium case
that does not mean that that that that
relation is not true
uh when the body is in motion so with
this background
uh discussion let us actually
try to develop uh our
our discussions towards the state of
stress at a point
and the plan is as follows so
when we want to discuss the state of
stress at a point
what we'll do is we will uh
we will start our uh so let me write
this down so we'll
we'll start by considering the balance
of linear momentum
so this again should highlight to you
how close the connection is between
mechanics of solids
and fluid mechanics so this is our plan
that will start our discussion with the
balance of linear momentum
okay now when we do that
uh you will see that
we will end up using one
very important one another very
important
balance principle which is the balance
of mass
or the conservation of mass which you
studied very very
uh well in your feed mechanics course or
your thermoplate science course
but again here i want to emphasize it
that many of our textbooks of solid
mechanics or mechanics of solids
are written in such a way that it kind
of gives the impression
that by not referring ever
by not referring ever to the balance of
mass or conservation of mass
it kind of gives the impression that
those kinds of balances
are or that kind of balance for mass is
uh
perhaps important only for fluid
mechanics as if the continuity equation
holds only true for feed mechanics
and has nothing whatsoever to do with
solid mechanics that is completely wrong
as long as you are working under the
purview of continuum mechanics
in general continuum mechanics which
doesn't matter whether it is feed
mechanics
or solid mechanics balance of mass has
to hold true
okay you have no other option that must
must hold true that is the
that is the foundation now now we'll use
that balance of mass
in our balance of linear momentum and
you will see how the balance of linear
momentum
will help us very naturally to go
towards
this connection between traction which
we studied in our previous part of the
lecture
and the state of stress which you want
to develop towards
okay so so
so uh the the things the kind of things
that we are going to write down here
it will be very very reminiscent of the
things that you studied
in your field mechanics or thermophilic
science course so for balance of linear
momentum
uh we will write this first of all in
the
integral form okay now
if you remember uh and and because this
is kind of a reputation for all of you
both the mechanical and the
manufacturing guys
uh i will uh i will
i will not go into the uh into the deep
details
of discussing this uh
however if if you really want to have
a more elaborate discussion maybe for
the purpose of revision or maybe to
clear
some lingering doubts uh maybe you can
uh
can and post this in our discussion
uh or something similar maybe some email
or something
and and maybe i can i can record a
separate uh separate lecture altogether
uh as a as a complement to this okay so
so the plan is like this that i will
discuss the balance of linear momentum
writing out everything completely but
not but not discussing
in too much detail
so the first thing that we are going to
write is the
material derivative okay the material
time derivative
of the linear momentum written in
integral form
so rho is the mass density of the
material
v is the velocity of course and that is
integrated
over a certain volume let's consider a
three-dimensional volume to keep things
general
okay so you understand that this balance
of linear momentum is just a rewrite
of the newton's second law of motion
okay so that's basically what it is is
basically
a sophisticated way of writing f is
equal to m
a so what we have written here uh f
is equal to m a or or perhaps uh even
more generally
f is equal to the time rate of change of
the linear momentum that's
that form of the newton's second law so
that is this
on the left hand side that is the time
rate of the change of linear momentum
this rho v so you can think of this like
rho times the dv the density times the
dv elemental volume
that gives you the elemental mass and
elemental mass times the
velocity that gives you the linear
momentum and integrated over the
volume that gives it that gives you the
total uh
linear momentum uh okay and ddt of
course is the time derivative
okay and on the right hand side
we need to write down the various
contributions from the forces
now these forces can be body forces they
can be surface forces
so for body forces we'll write down
like this
so dou is again the mass density uh
so b is the uh is the force
per unit mass and
integrated over the entire volume and
finally
and this is where the first step towards
establishing the connection between
stresses
and attractions will take place
we are going to write down the the
surface forces in terms of the traction
okay so this is
t ts
okay where s is the where the d s is the
elemental surface and s is the
entire surface uh of the body under
consideration
so you can imagine that we are again
considering a general three dimensional
body
like we had been considering in our
previous part of the lecture so a
genuine three-dimensional body like this
and now what we are doing is that
in the in the previous class we had
considered this traction
vector to be
uh to be concerned or relevant to this
internal point
what we are doing today is to consider
this to be
a point this for a point lying on the
surface
so instead of flying this line point p
lying inside it
we are just shifting this point p on the
surface is absolutely no difference
okay uh okay
now uh you see first of all what we'll
do is we'll deal with this left hand
side
okay we'll deal with this left hand side
uh and we want to
recast into a form such that
this integration which which is having a
ddt in front of it
will be recast in a way such that uh
there is nothing sitting in front of it
so it will start looking this
integration this volume integration
it will start looking like this okay you
see there is nothing in front of this
integration there is no ddt term here
uh furthermore our our plan
later on will be to somehow recast this
also
uh in uh in terms of a volume integral
but that is for later let's not worry
about that
right now so first of all
we'll deal with this uh left hand side
term
now
ddt
rho v dv okay now this is the part
where i will uh i will
quicken my pace a little bit
so had this been
a face-to-face lecture i would spend a
little bit of time
asking some of you about how we proceed
from here
so maybe you can pause your video a
little bit and think how how we can
proceed
so basically what we are going to do
here uh
is to use the reynolds transport theorem
okay
so some of you may be wondering like
reynolds transport theorem we studied
in fluid mechanics or thermofit science
what is it doing in
solid mechanics well as i said there is
a very very close relation as far as the
development of
these these fundamental concepts is
involved
and practically there is no difference
between the way we deal with free
mechanics or solid mechanics it is all
part of continuum mechanics
okay so we are going to use the reynolds
transport theorem
and now what we will do is
we'll write it like this rho the del del
t
of rho v dv
plus the rho v term again
okay this rho v is the same row v as
here
but now
this surface term okay
now we don't want to keep it in the form
of a surface term so
you understand that this is basically
the so we are
writing from from uh from here to here
using the reynolds transport theorem
okay now i don't want to keep it
in the form of the surface integration i
want to recast this in the in in a
volume integral form
so what can i do i can just use my gauss
divergence theorem
and very encouragingly uh every time i
have asked this question
uh to to to your seniors in the past two
three years
uh uh innovatively someone or the other
gave the correct answer that we have to
use the gauss divergence theorem
that's very nice and i believe many of
you have already
answered this in your head correctly
that this is indeed the gauss divergence
theorem
anyway so uh so what we'll do is
we'll rewrite this entire thing in terms
of
a volume integral like this this remains
as it is
but this one will be in the form
of a divergence okay this will be in the
form of a divergence
the row v term will remain as it is
okay however
we have this
this entire thing is under this volume
integration
okay so because when you convert this
to the volume integration you have the
integration over volume
over this now you see what is this
thing what what is going on here i have
not put a dot
i have not put anything here so uh it is
a little bit confusing
uh because this row is a scalar no
problem
but this v is a vector this
is again the same vector v so
if we had put a dot here
what would have happened if i put a dot
here
then this entire entity would have
become a scalar quantity
now the divergence
this gradient operator with the dot that
is the divergence
that cannot act on a scalar so surely
we cannot have a dot bit between this
row v and this v that would have made it
a scalar
now that this divergence would be just
wrong
so this is not a dot uh
what should it be well the
correct symbol that we are missing here
is the
tensor product or the dyadic product
here okay
so uh this is the part
where i am not going to discuss uh
too much because i believe this should
have been covered in your food mechanics
courses
but again i am telling you if some of
you have some problem please let me know
through the discussion forum
or email or something and maybe i can go
into the
into some more detail of it okay
now what we'll do is we will use take
this expression
okay we take this expression and
we'll try to see how this can be
simplified a little bit
because you see i have started with the
balance of linear momentum
and in that process i had told you
that even when you are considering
balance of linear momentum somehow the
balance of mass has to be used
i told you that but till now we have not
used it you will see how
how that comes comes into play okay so
uh in the next
uh slide on the next page i'm going to
just repeat this thing and then continue
okay so i just quickly repeated so ddt
proven
this one uh i'll just repeat this last
line here quickly
so uh integration over volume
uh d
del del t of rho v
plus divergence of rho v
again okay now comes a very crucial step
what i will do is i will i can break
this up
uh using um the simple chain rule of
derivations so this will be
uh rho
del v del t plus
del rho del t with a v
no problem there but this one
this one is far more complicated okay uh
and again
because i believe this would have been
covered in your queer mechanics or
thermo fit science
i will not cover it in detail okay but
again the promise remains that if you if
you're not sure about this
do let me know uh so proceeding
what we'll do is we'll just use one
vector identity or the tensor identity
so to speak
we'll quickly write down the expression
so when you break this thing apart okay
carry out the divergence properly so so
you get this
it's as if this one is first acting on
this
but it's not so simple as that's okay so
you get this thing
and then by some magic you get this
thing out and
this one operates on this you get this
please note here
that this this is just a row v
dotted with the grad and this entire
thing operating on the v
please note that okay so it is not the
this part is not the divergence of v it
is just
the grad of the if you just consider it
separately that is the grad of v
i think it is it is much more intuitive
if you think of it
like the row v dotted with the gradient
operator so that is like a scalar
operator that is operating on this v
okay i won't spend too much time on this
anymore
so what happens now is that
we can collect some common terms you see
what we'll do is
you see there's a v here v vector here
there's a v vector here we'll take that
common
so v vector common del rho del t
plus delta dot
rho v keep that together
next whatever remains this rho del v del
t
plus rho whatever this term is that will
take
together taking the rho s common
so
del v del t plus v
dot grad p
now you tell me whatever i am doing here
is it not the same
as what you have encountered in your
feed mechanics or your term of great
science course
i believe you will you will definitely
remember it to be the
almost the same thing in fact not not
almost exactly the same thing
now you tell me what is this
this part okay i want you to focus your
attention
on this part
del del t plus delta dot rho v what is
this
okay so by
conservation of mass
[Music]
what we have actually is del rho del t
plus delta dot rho v
that is equal to zero in the context of
fluid mechanics or thermo fluid signs i
am sure you have come across this
this equation and this is the famous
continuity equation
and this again comes up in the context
of studying solid mechanics
okay in fact it is like a very
artificial distinction as far as these
initial
parts of our lectures are concerned uh
it's it's exactly the same thing it's
just continuum mechanics right now
okay so because this thing is zero
in general because you have conservation
of mass
so this entire term is zero which means
basically what you have
is
that d dt integration
rho v dv
is equal to integration
over the entire volume of this term
so basically i'm just rewriting this
term here
and what is this particular font
so this is nothing but the material
derivative
of the velocity vector so this is rho
dv dt
please note that you should not fall
into the trap
of very naively taking this ddt inside
this volume integral please do not do
that you have to use the
uh like in the previous slide you can
see
please resist the temptation of just
arbitrarily
taking this ddt inside it okay and using
the chain rule uh
so you have to properly use the reynolds
transport theorem
uh and then proceed okay
so when we do all of this we we end up
with this thing
and this is how and this is what i meant
when i initially said that
we have to consider the balance of
linear momentum and you will see that
the balance of mass
will be inherently used here okay and as
as you see we have actually used this
the conservation of mass or the balance
of mass
we have actually used so we end up with
this particular
expression so if we go back to our
original equation of the balance of mass
this left hand side we have kind of
simplified
and we have achieved our objective of
making this integration
to be rewritten in such a form that
there is no time derivative sitting in
front as you can see here
so this ddt of the of this this is the
volume integral
so this has been rewritten in a form
such that there is no time derivative
there is no material time derivative
sitting in the front
okay now if we substitute this
expression
back here you will see that on the left
hand side
the volume integration is again like
this particular volume integration form
okay so uh
since this very important step is done
i'll i'll
let you take a breather and stop this
part of the lecture
here and proceed exactly from this point
in the next part of the lecture
thank you very much